hi in this quick tutorial I'm going to
show you how you can use the translation
tools in Microsoft Publisher to quickly
translate text into any of the languages
supported by Microsoft translator the
translator team is having a party and
I'm sending invitations to our team in
China to attend via Skype or in person
if they can I want to print the card in
Chinese but I don't know the language
luckily I can use the translation
features in publisher to translate the
card automatically to translate the text
I select the text I want to translate
click on the review tab at the top of
the window
and choose translate selected text
now a research window opens up on the
right side of the screen in the research
window I can choose the language I want
to translate the text to from all of the
languages supported by Microsoft
translator for this block of text I want
to translate from English to Chinese I
can press insert to replace the text or
copy to add the translation to my
clipboard so that I can use it somewhere
else in the document here I'll click
insert and the text is automatically
translated into Chinese if you use the
translation features a lot you may want
to add translate to the quick access
toolbar at the top to do this simply
click on the customize quick access
toolbar button at the top select more
commands choose the review tab and
select translate selected text from the
menu once you've highlighted translate
selected text from the menu press add
and okay and now the translate feature
will appear at the top of the quick
access toolbar thanks a lot for your
time I hope this video has been helpful
in learning about the translation
features in Microsoft Publisher for more
videos about Microsoft translator check
out our youtube channel at WWE kao ms /
translator youtube thanks a lot
you